we call them grievous no one's ever seen
one and live to tell about it
but they're out there 100 foot tall
moving walls giant creatures
desolate cities you can bet cgi played a
huge part in bringing the maze runner
films to life
while there wasn't actually a ton of
green screen used in the film
cgi was key to bring everything from the
scenery to the grievers to life
method studios had 170 people working
for 10 months creating 530 cgi shots
just for the first film
let's break it down and see how it all
worked what is this place
let me show you the maze in the maze
runner is obviously a key element and
the team did not disappoint
as we can see here the actors are
actually in a pretty large open green
space with a few blue screens that were
around them marking spots where the
walls of the maze are then cgi'd in
never go beyond those walls we can see
in this shot that the walls moving in
were in part real
but the structures they filmed were much
smaller in scale and needed cgi to
complete the look
why would you tell me what's out there
trying to protect you man for your own
good uh you guys can't just keep me here
can't let you leave
check out how much depth is actually
created by after effects
these long daunting hallways look so
real as for the overall maze itself
we can see there are several layers that
contribute to the construction
of this realistic looking landscape the
structure itself the sandy dunes
and a bit of light and smoke to really
finish off the scene
maze is a dangerous place it's one thing
to see gi a giant maze structure but
it's a whole other challenge to bring a
terrifying giant
moving maze to the screen realistically
is that even possible
it's hard to believe this sequence was
shot in just two days we can see that
the actors were really in a giant car
park with a 180 foot blue screen that
was 40 feet high
so what were the actors seeing otherwise
what the hell is this place
called blades well they had these few
blue poles in the lot marking where
certain walls would be
much less intimidating than what we see
in the movie jumping ahead to the third
film we see some incredibly complex and
impressive cgi work
especially near the end when teresa and
thomas are tragically separated
i'm sorry i tried
as we can see this terrifying roof scene
did still make use of some actual fire
but the level wasn't nearly as intense
as what we see in the final cut
this rooftop creation looks incredible
and with all the cgi edits
well it's one of the most terrifying
scenes by far thankfully there was far
less fire surrounding the actors while
they were actually shooting
and then of course the helicopter for
part of the shot the helicopter is fully
cgi created
but when they get closer to teresa and
thomas we can see that the helicopter
was a whole contraption built onto the
set
the doorway to the helicopter is fully
realized but the remainder surrounding
it is just a green screen enabling the
video effects magic to take over
oh yeah this building falling down total
cgi
while the whole scene looks very
dramatic with all the effects we have to
admit that even this scene without cgi
is wild
then we have the most intense point
teresa's fall
while she did have a slight fall we can
see that the actor is hooked up to wires
to help ease her down and the drop isn't
nearly as huge as the one we see in the
final cut
there was no shortage of dramatic and
exciting scenes in the third film the
death cure
this scene shows so much action but as
we can see
it was all actually pretty still the
scenery is all done with cgi but
how did they make it look like they were
speeding around well
in that case this giant fan does the
trick the way they had it all set up
definitely made these tricky looking
stunts much easier and safer
checking out what it looks like without
all the effects we have loads of people
actually physically manipulating the car
on set which still looks pretty amazing
we have to give it to them because the
final product is
incredible especially considering that
they had a relatively small budget of 62
million dollars to create all that they
did
that my friend was a griever
we can't talk about maze runner without
checking out how they brought the insane
creations that are the grievers to life
these guardians of the maze completely
created by cgi
the process to create them was super
complex we can see in these sketches how
much detail was put into creating the
perfect
terrifying creature what's up griever
yeah i saw one
you can just see it so how did they do
the scenes with the actors battling them
so well
cue the stuntmen in blue while they
aren't nearly as terrifying as the
creatures themselves they put up a
pretty good fight with the actors
check out these long blue poles they
used in the real battle on set
when we stay close we stick together we
get through this
we get out now we can see they're
holding large blue pads as well to help
build out the shape of what we see in
the final cat
definitely not so scary to run from as
for this scene the trick to making it
look like the griever was actually
lifting the actor up was having two
stunned people holding him up in this
giant rig
who knew stuntmen in blue morphsuits
could be so effective
oh and when the griever catches fire
yeah that's completely done with vfx
extremely good ones too it might seem
like a small detail but the running iv
we see throughout the maze is incredibly
complex
so much so that they actually created
brand new software to do it
if we look closely we can see how many
variances there are between the
thickness of vines and the leaves
themselves
plus the fact that they turn towards
light just like real ivy
they don't try and climb into the top
the ivy doesn't go all the way to the
top
this edition played even more of a role
than you'd think they were actually
responsible for differentiating the look
between
scenes that were filmed in the exact
same location it's time now to begin
phase two the second film in the
franchise had plenty of cgi
all these giant abandoned and desolate
buildings yeah that's
all computer generated the creation of
these was actually pretty complicated
to make it accurate they first created
full cities and then
broke them down so they look like what
we see in the movie they used a special
technology called particle-based
weathering which allowed the city to
decay in the most realistic way possible
no wonder it looks so incredible
what the hell happened to this place it
doesn't look like anyone's been here in
a long time
oh and these giant sandy dunes you can
bet those are all created by the effects
artists
the sand wasn't just added in loosely
though the artists actually did
simulations to see how sand really moved
in the wind and then replicated the
ripple patterns that would actually
appear
check out how natural these look then
there are the sewers filled with evil
cranks
all cgi the motions of the cranks was
motion captured by circus actors who
were double jointed
and the result is super terrifying and
creepy
cgi was used to add in all the strange
veiny and vine like looking details on
their faces as well
and welcome to the safe raymond let's
talk about some of the scenery
it's pretty vast and really brings the
worlds to life
in the films there were hundreds of
shots of the environment that were all
cgi
including this one of a helicopter
flying through the sandy dunes welcome
to the glade
the glade itself in the first film was
actually a real location
but not nearly as big as we see on
screen we can see in this shot there's a
small part of the maze built
this facade is where a lot of the
dialogue scenes were filmed up close
we don't belong here hey this place
is in our home the walls we see here are
only 20 feet high but the cgi used
extends everything we see to appear much
much larger
shadows had to be considered as well and
was simulated so they were all uniform
and matching where the light was hitting
walls
i never thought i'd say it i missed the
glade
oh yeah and this elevator shot not so
dramatic when we see that it was just a
cage surrounded by green
it's honestly a bit surprising to see so
many seemingly simple shots needing cgi
to be done
but our glade was a real location it was
his own little world
we can't believe how much work went into
creating these movies
and so flawlessly as well while we knew
they likely didn't build hundred foot
tall moving walls and destroyed cities
we never could have guessed how much cgi
contributed to creating the environments
we have to say though impressive as the
grievers are we are also pretty big fans
of the blue stuntmen running around with
poles